write the conditional statement in if
then form and the statement is dogs have
four legs which we know is true so
another way of thinking about it you say
well
if you have a dog or if an animal is a
dog then it's going to have four legs
that's an equivalent statement to this
year so let's see if we can construct a
sentence like that so if
if an animal
is a dog
if an animal is a dog
then it has four legs so that was pretty
straightforward let's do a few more of
these
so here same thing we want to write this
in if then form i will win a gold medal
when i go to the olympics
so let's see this is essentially saying
if i go to the olympics then i will win
a gold medal so if
if i
go to the olympics
then
i win a gold medal now you might be
tempted to say hey well you know i saw
gold medal first here and then i saw
olympics later in the sentence but this
isn't saying that if you win a gold
medal then you have then you have gone
to the olympics or then you will go to
the olympics you might win a gold medal
at like the local track meet or
something and that's not going to ensure
that you're going to the olympics this
is saying that if you go to the olympics
because there's this person is very
confident who's ever saying this i will
win a gold medal when i go to the
olympics so that's the same statement
saying when i go to the olympics if or
if i go to the olympics i'm going to win
a gold medal so if i go to the olympics
then i win a gold medal and actually
this statement is a little bit more
confident than this one because here
they say if i go to the olympics well
here they say when i go to the olympics
but i think you get the idea let's do a
couple more of these
i will go to disneyland when i win a
gold medal so now the winning the gold
medal is what's driving stuff to happen
so if i win a gold medal then i will go
to disneyland
so if
if i
win
a gold medal
then
i go to disneyland
oh that wasn't right oh i didn't put
this
i go to disneyland i got too careless i
got to make sure to win if i win a gold
medal then i go to disneyland and now we
got it right let's do one more i can't
do enough of these these are incredibly
fun
isosceles triangles have two equal sides
so if i have if i have an isosceles
triangle then i have two equal sides
so if
i have
if a shape
is
an isosceles triangle
then
it has
two
two equal sides
we got it right